hey guys just want to let you know now
starting to get some dates on the books
uh september 16th through 18th i'll be
at the phoenix house of comedy this is a
makeup show
uh from before the virus and uh go to
ryansickler.com for all my live dates
you'll start to see them there i
also want to let you know this is
something people been asking for years
people have been saying
you got to make a ringtone of your laugh
i don't know why anybody would want that
i can't understand why anybody would
want to hear that on their phone
but after years of messages comments
i did it we got ringtones of my laugh
coming
i promise you we'll put a promo out and
blast it out so you know where to get
them
but uh i heard yous and you're about to
hear me on your phone all the time all
right
this episode of the honeydew is brought
to you by upstart raycon
and coors pure more on that later let's
get into the do
the honeydew with ryan zickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i'm ryan sickler
ryan sickler.com ryan sickle on all your
social medias
subscribe to the youtube page i got to
tell you that we're coming up on 100
000 if we're not there yet like i said
i'm
so grateful and thankful in one year
we've hit 100 thousand subscribers
and um like i said i don't i don't know
if that's good or not
i don't really give a [ __ ] that's what
we're doing i'm keeping my head down
focusing with you all and we're gonna
hit those numbers all right i'm not
looking left or right anymore i'm
looking straight ahead
at y'all all right speaking of y'all if
you love the honeydew and you gotta have
more
subscribe to my patreon the honeydew
with you all it's only five bucks a
month if you sign up for a year
you get over a month free and we are now
including video of the honeydew a day
early
ad free at no additional cost for the
rest of
2021 all right so you get the entire
back catalog
plus honeydew a day early ad free
all for five bucks a month again if you
sign up for a year
it's a month free all right um and that
community continues to grow
and just blow me away with the stories
it's it's
i love my [ __ ] job y'all i love
my [ __ ]
job all right you know i record here at
the santa monica music center
uh very excited about working with
outreach through the arts helping these
kids out podcasting teaching them
uh some useful tools moving forward all
right um
so when that's out i'll be promoting it
but i wanted to just get the awareness
out you know i like to talk about it and
help these kids they're working with the
santa monica police department
um so we're gonna get a lot of dialogue
going and some interesting stuff's gonna
come out of that
now you know we do here we highlight the
low lights
these are the stories behind the
storytellers and night pants nation i am
very excited to bring
back here second time on the do y'all
ladies and gentlemen please welcome back
jesse bay paluso everybody welcome back
hey
doing it on the do you had such a great
episode on the first one here
we went deep by the way cheers first
first beer ever on the dew
yes has some cores pure organic you know
times have changed when a beer like
cores has gone organic
it's legit and it's good it is really 92
calories no sugar
it does contain alcohol it is delicious
organic we're day drinking can we say
that yeah we can
are we going to get canceled no no we're
going to get sponsored
by coors pure it is it's super delicious
i asked him like i need i need a beer
you got a beer
yeah that's the kind of year it's been
um
will you please before we get into what
we're going to talk about today plug
everything please yes um i am jessie may
paluso
[Laughter]
um at trustymatebaluso on ig
jessiemaypaluso
youtube is just youtube.com forward
slash jessie maypoluso
um podcast
i have a show coming out on netflix i
can't say the name but
look out for it in june or july of this
summer show
really all right i was one of the very
few people who
actually got to work a little during the
most tumultuous year
and also i partnered with this
amazing coffee alternative company
called mudwater
and it's what saved me through the years
with just having anxiety and dealing
with as you know how my life has been
for the past three years has been
[ __ ] crazy
um and i had to stop drinking coffee
because it also
made me spin out and have anxiety
attacks you really you nailed it back to
that and that really yeah that helped
once i stopped drinking coffee i like
could sleep at night a little bit
okay um but mudwater and i are working
together and so we're doing
i think it's like fifteen percent off
their entire purchase mudwater.com
forward slash jessie may
use code jessie may mud mud what about
that what have they done taking the
ingredient out like some of the
marijuana's these days they're taking
the um
ingredient outfit that makes you panic
are you
just like a dad some of the marijuanas
these days
yes dad zaddy i call you zaddy you're a
total daddy
i love that you do it's my favorite set
of marijuana
cigarettes kids better not be having any
of those goddamn marijuana cigarettes
are you on the jazz cabbage god damn it
joshua i've never heard jasmine my
friend chris calls it
as cabbage and i can't not call it that
that's a brand new one i've heard all
the devil's lettuce and all that [ __ ]
but i've
never heard jazz it's the greatest um no
it's not
it's a coffee alternative but they have
mushrooms in it but not the kind that
i add to it like the fun kind oh not the
kind you it's like
you know healthy adaptogens like rishi
chaga ashwagandha and then i put the
[ __ ] mushrooms
by the way ryan and i just to be clear
have been talking for three hours
already and then he's like we should
probably start recording
no i i just love you because we had this
moment right when you got out of the car
i haven't seen you since we recorded
here at last
and you parked out in front of the
studio and i have to say i'm feeling
really cute today yeah yeah
yeah you always like [ __ ] the thing that
you said what is it maxed and waxed
ready to party
i'm walking over across the street and
uh there's this
old lady behind behind you old
i saw her i was like she was banged up
yeah and she was walking up the street
and i just saw you coming out of the car
and he looked cute and everything and i
said what's up girl
and you were like hey i was like hey
daddy
how you doing it's not free if you're
asking you got to pay for all this
you're like oh no i was like sorry i was
talking to her behind you what's up
jesse
like it was not like i see you every 10
minutes and then you told me to not step
in dog poop
[Laughter]
you look back that old lady was looking
at us like she was my girl
she really did think i yelled at her my
favorite though was when how you went
what's up jesse like you're like you
were bothered by my presence wow you're
here
great i guess i got a another coffee mug
do i get to keep this one yeah now i
have a pair
yeah now you're in my house i love it in
my heart i love it
you are for sure um
look we had such a great episode last
time and did not get to talk about
i mean obviously there's so much more to
talk about but
i do want to talk about your dad this
time can we talk about your dad you can
totally talk about my dad and
i know you're at a point where you're
comfortable at least talking about it
but also
you're so involved in in the cause and
things like i want you to educate
not only me but some of us about what
goes on yeah for sure
my you know alzheimer's is a brutal
disease my dad actually
we think it's a heart disease to
diagnose because it's in that sort of
wheelhouse of parkinson's and any sort
of neurodegenerative disease
that sometimes shows up as one thing and
it's actually something else but
so not to put you on the spot or i just
want to know maybe you do maybe you
don't what is the
difference between alzheimer's
and dementia well dementia or is it part
of
it's well dementia's more of like an
umbrella
term because there's a lot of there's a
lot of different types of dementia
there's like blue body which
was what brought robin williams had
there's uh vascular dementia which is
technically what my father was diagnosed
with
what we think he had because of his
symptoms and alzheimer's is the leading
cause alzheimer's is
the one that is you know the the most
um uh brutal and abrasive and
the one that takes the most lives um
and it's it's crazy because you know
it's a sort of thing where the symptoms
reveal themselves so sneakily
because in this society i'm going to
start getting in my head every symptom
you say i'm like i had that last week
she's over here saying alzheimer's is
the michael jordan of dementia for
christ's sake i mean
that's not the one i want man oh you
know what i mean give me the white guy
off the bench kind of dementia
something i can deal with like a basic
[ __ ] can i get the starter kit
let me get the starter kit dementia do
you just want to forget your keys or do
you want to forget your keys your wife
and where you live
because we can give you that
introduction package
but if you also want to not know who you
are and where you are that's going to be
excellent at all times oh my god at all
times
oh my god can i take that yeah and turn
it into a joke take that i put it in my
alzheimer's chunk
it's yours
see there's so much misconception around
the disease
you know alzheimer's it's alzheimer's um
named after the doctor who discovered it
um dr terence johnston
john smith
people have never been known to call it
old-timers
yeah i hear that a lot well that or all
timers also i hear that as well there's
so many
wrong ways of saying it but old-timers
comes from
obviously it being a phonetic symbol or
sounding phonetically similar but people
in our society
equate old age with dementia
and that is not a normal part of the
aging process
so calling it old-timers like yeah you
know everyone does that like oh grandma
she's getting forgetful she's got
old-timers
that's not that's not how we should age
right it's a disease
it's an inflammation of the brain and it
is not
a normal part of the aging process like
that's the most important thing for
people to take away
that just because you get old doesn't
mean you lose your memory it's not
normal no it's not normal it's it's it's
purely
it's it's directly uh connected to
a disease and it is a disease it's
really interesting and important to know
because it's not like it's your hearing
no it's your mind this is your mind and
the mind is a very interesting
organ it's one of the only organs that
we can only look at posthumously it's
not something we can really study
the way we can study other parts of our
body without
really injuring us i gotta tell you this
um when we were i just had graduated
high school and uh my really good friend
recently brother to me yeah
yikes listen i got it done all right you
know what i mean
20 20 was brought whatever you didn't
get a ged got a god i went back
this guy's still in high school he's
just in there that's where night pants
came from
you're like i got to get my ged i'm
wearing these pants come on
um so yeah i just graduated college and
my
my friend who's like a brother still
family to me and and his little sister
was killed in a car accident and we're
all there in the hospital
and uh i'm talking to the doctor and
we're talking about the soul
and i'll never forget this guy saying
this because every he said
i said where do you what do you do you
believe in the soul and he's like yeah i
absolutely do i go where do you think it
is
in the body and he's like i think it's
in the mind i go now why do you say that
and he goes i'll tell you
i can change your [ __ ] kidneys i can
change your
heart i can change all these things i
can give you a new knee a new shoulder a
little
all these things about you and you're
still you but the moment we just
lit a flick of the brain can change
everything about who you are and he's
like that's why i believe the brain is
in this or the souls in the brain i was
like
dude that's fantastic i believe that too
i mean if you look at the brain
if you look at how the brain works
and like the synapses and the firing
between
the synapses it's literally it looks
like the universe
and it's it's much like the universe in
that it's in cas
encapsulated in darkness and we don't
really understand it
yet it's all-encompassing and it's where
we come from and so it's just this
interesting comparative between like
what the
universe is like and what our brain is
like i i believe that that's a really
astute way of looking at the soul i
never thought about the soul being in
the brain that's
very interesting and you know isn't it i
thought i just was like yeah you're
right
because any any all any alt even
i had another friend whose father passed
a brain cancer
and the one doctor said look any time
you have to open the head
just opening it is your you know there's
airborne [ __ ] that could get in there
and cause infections and you got to open
it again and opening the head is never
good once
you know it's not great so the brain is
i didn't realize this because i went to
see a psychiatrist i had him on my
podcast because i've been
following brain health and reading about
brain health ever since my father was
diagnosed
and this dr daniel amen who
is a psychiatrist and he's been doing
these spec scans of the brain it's
single photon
emitted computer tomography and it takes
a
scan of your brain and just looks at the
tomography of your brain and
sees where there might be injury and he
he told me an astounding and astonishing
statistic in fact that he says that 80
of mental health issues like mental
illness
is due to directly due to an injury a
physical injury on the brain
which means a lot of these people who
are walking around with
i mean depression being a blanket term
but you know
psychosis and schizophrenia and all
these other sort of
terms within psychiatry that are
affecting so many people
some of it is caused from a physical
injury to your brain
and then he told me that the brain's
consistent consistency
is like butter and so when you think
about that and you think about the
damage that people do to their brain
on a daily basis whether it's you know
vices or alcohol or drugs
and then add in tbis and ctes like
actual physical injury to the brain it's
not
really built in a way to be
treated like that so you know it's just
there's this one time my dad's
trajectory of him being sick we were
talking about the soul being in the
brain
and it made me think of this it was
and i'll talk about like sort of the
progression of the disease and how hard
it is
it's like i do want my first question is
what's who
and what was the first thing noticed but
but tell them yes i will get i would do
tell me um what you were just about to
say about the soul your dad
in in the process of him being sick
there was this one moment where he just
was
so restless sat down and he just didn't
want to sit down and he wanted to get up
and then he's like i got to sit down and
he
was going through this just cyclical
anxiety induced moment and he just
couldn't find
calm anywhere and and he's standing
there and i was like dad just
what do you need how can i help and he
said
something to me in in hindsight that
is so difficult to for
the disease is difficult to equate
because it exists within the mind
so when somebody is sick with this
disease how can they verbalize what's
going on
and this was that instance where my
father said i i
i just can't calm the chaos in my
mind i don't know what's happening in my
mind
i'm losing my mind and that was the last
time that my dad was able
to quantify
what he was feeling and then it just
sort of took over
but to answer your question
that's the hardest thing to
decipher with this disease because it is
such a slow [ __ ]
burn and it's the sort of thing
where in hindsight it all makes sense
all the things that you threw away and
just chopped up to
old timers or just being dead you know
many times as a family
we say oh that's just dad just dad
you know this disease it manifests later
in life but it starts
early how early it's as early as your
30s
and this is not me i've got crazy brain
fog right now i'm not even joking from
this virus
they say brain fog's real well it's like
i don't remember like my short-term
memory has been [ __ ] by this thing
uh and then i started thinking this [ __ ]
like you get i don't want to freak
everybody out
but like why am i putting peanut butter
in the fridge
well cause you want a hard nut and i
like that flavor
yeah you want a little hard nut you want
to put your apple slice and put a little
hard nut on it i'm here for that snack
for getting that now all of a sudden
well that's different
see that's the manifestation that's the
symptoms i'm talking about
the implementation of lifestyle
external factors environmental factors
certain things within your
genealogy and your familial influence on
your body and your soul and everything
being able to contract this disease
starts early and that's another
misconception that people need to
realize this is
i truly believe through our
medical uh the advancements in medical
technology that we're going to
be able to pinpoint this disease a
little bit more because it's like the
number five
killer of people in our country yeah it
is about five it's like
it's like in our our top three have to
do with you know
heart disease and things like that
because we're all
completely out of shape and eat like
trash but
alzheimer's and dementia is like number
six five or six
of of all time of killers of all killers
in in our country so that's a huge
that's a huge number in the top five um
so wait you're telling me if we just
have better diets we could this could
reach number one
we gotta do better come on y'all
we need to get to number one feature kid
cheeseburgers and screaming
nobody gives a [ __ ] there's not enough
charities for five and six we gotta get
up there again
there's truth to that [ __ ] i mean we
that's a whole other podcast about the
business of illness
i know the business of illness yeah it's
it's
that that part is is alarming but like
through conversations like this we can
sort of
break stigmas and the other stigma is
that
this is just something that old people
deal with well old people deal with it
because it happened
it's been happening it's been happening
dealing with the the re the
what then the repercussions
repercussions of the
[ __ ] that's been going on for decades
yes the way they lived the food
um the stress level there's so many
things that go into it from the things
that i've studied and have read and
have found a lot of it is diet
so much of our food causes internal
inflammation and a lot of oxidative
stress in our body and
i'm not a doctor i'm saying a lot of big
words
most of the words i understand but i've
read a lot and have tried to educate
myself because then i was scared like
oh [ __ ] am i gonna forget too cause my
dad did
like i got his chimples and his
hemorrhoids am i gonna get his [ __ ]
alzheimer's that is that wrong
are we going three for three bro
you know you talk about traits my mom
gave me like long legs nice hair
good smile my dad's like hemorrhoids
pimples and acne and
alzheimer's good luck but don't worry
you're gonna forget about it all in your
70s
there might be something to it you know
i mean everyone's like oh i don't want
to forget really
have you seen the past year yeah there's
a couple dicks i'd really like to forget
i want like selective alzheimer's for
the dicks i've let in my body
just turn it on for that thing i just
like i'm not totally against alzheimer's
if i
can't forget all those things of all
time yeah that would be really
really nice yeah so i'm gonna change my
campaign get awesome
you get 12 alzheimer's uh get out of
jail all right i'm gonna take that on
jason's dick give me one on jason's dick
all right i don't remember that dick
all right okay just get chips but
remember me i don't even know who the
[ __ ] you are no i don't and i don't
remember me so therefore your dick was
ever inside of me bye
key things bye um one of the first
things we recognized
i wasn't there and how old was your dad
at the time this was
2017 september 28 2017 i believe
uh actually no september 30th it was on
his birthday i was
doing a weekend in sacramento at what is
that club there is it a
punch line and i actually it was a
weekend where i was
the first weekend i was spending with my
new man and i was like all excited you
know i'm gonna go do the road and you
can see my life
and we're gonna hang out and have some
hotel sex and all this stuff and i'm
gonna try not to get pregnant
i'm trying not oh yeah it's so hard
i'm allergic to condoms i just don't
like them they smell weird it's like i
feel like
they do smell weird yeah i feel like i
work in a factory that makes gloves
after i have sex with condoms hey guys
i'm safe i swear
um no it's just a latex from my [ __ ]
it's fine we're good
who did you what did you yell at who's
over there
anyone out there elizabeth laugh this
much with everybody
i feel like half of her
time was just us wheezing so
i'm like telling this like one of the
[Music]
worst
like literally the worst moment of my
life
i can't literally like if i think
on my deathbed what was the worst moment
it's not this
but it was what i'm about to tell you
but this is this is why this podcasts
are important
podcasts are
oh jesus christ so i'm sitting on the
stairwell
my mom sent me a text message that said
something's wrong with your dad
so they were still together no my
parents have been separated since i was
about
nine okay and my mom's remained really
close they're both
really close until they both died
oh my god i know your mom i'm so sorry
your mom passed
just over there they were close until
they both died i think they were close
until one of them
yeah they were close to one of them died
when they both died they got closer
yeah now they're they're as close as
they can we're back
we're back um
you're orphans you said that's what you
said outside yeah i'm orphaned now which
is
the most humbling experience ever
um but that'll be i guess that'll be our
third installment of our
podcast trilogy yeah my mom just said
there's something wrong with your father
and she went over to take him out for
his birthday i guess they couldn't get a
hold of him he wasn't answering his
phone
and she pulled up in his the trunk of
his car was
open and he wasn't down there and the
door was locked
and she went upstairs he let her in and
he was trying to
call someone back on his remote
and so she just was like this is not
old-timers this isn't normal
right and that was in september
of 2017. december 30th
yeah on his birthday what birthday
september 30th number
how old he was 81 81 yeah and i was
supposed to be born on his birthday but
i actually
they had me come out two weeks early and
my other sister was born on his birthday
for real yeah isn't that well
very wild uh you know
crazy of people yeah your two daughters
you're
both your daughters yeah but your dad
and your sister celebrate a birthday
together
they do that's got to be bittersweet i'm
sure it is
um and and so from that point that was
the first tangible thing
but there was something earlier in the
summer that now we know what it was
he was having equilibrium issues and
said he felt dizzy and he couldn't quite
you know his surroundings were a little
off to him and so we just thought
it was just we didn't know what it was
and honestly
i hate to say this out loud but i think
it needs to be said
our our medical and
hospital businesses i hate to say
businesses
our health care system sucks and it
failed my family
and it's not their fault it's not one
person's fault
sure it's an accumulative years of
[ __ ] up-ness going on throughout
that's one of the most frustrating
factors of this it's just
you know there's not enough information
or there's not enough drive to get the
information i don't know i don't know
what the [ __ ] solution is
but there were so many areas and maybe
maybe it's me just trying to hang on
and have that sort of grief moment where
you want to blame somebody
and be able to put it to something but i
also know other people have gone through
this
a similar scenario where they felt that
they didn't get
care and hands-on care and somebody who
actually was like you know
let me think outside the box a little
bit instead of referencing some book
from 1995
that is completely out of date you know
so
early on in the summer with the
equilibrium issues we brought him to a
neurologist
and she you know my father up to that
point had been a very functional
alcoholic drinking you know
he used to count his drinks oh really
my dad would count his drinks he had
vodka soda and lime
and he would use the same glass and have
the bartender just
freshen up the lime and he would count
the limes by the end of the night to
know when it was time to stop
i mean he would stop at like eight or
nine obviously
the system didn't really work i think
it's just when the cup got filled with
the limes he's like i'm good
yeah but and he was never he was a fun
drunk
it was never a drinking where we were
like oh we gotta talk to dad we just
accepted it and
he never called us in the middle of
night crying about vietnam
he never raised his hand to us he just
wanted to hit on women and
laugh and tell jokes and he was the most
joking
drink course pure light beer coors pure
organic
organic but better for you
he never raised his hand he was just a
very affable man
and um so when we brought him did he
ever remarry
no no he's a different did he date
though he tried
he he dated i really was this one woman
um
i can't remember her name but she was a
lawyer and she had a son and they were
together for a while and i was like
really this i was about 16.
i was like oh this could be something
good for him but he had so many
you know that generation didn't come
from
a place a safe place for them to be able
to deal with the demons that their
parents
had instilled on them sure you know
we're talking like turn of the centuries
we're the first real i feel like we're
the first generation of people like all
right let's get our [ __ ] together let's
talk
yeah let's communicate let's talk about
it let's let's
unpack our [ __ ] let's abnormalize
unpacking our [ __ ]
this generation they shoved it put it in
a suitcase taped it glued it shut and
put it in the bottom of the ocean
and was like go out and have another
family happen
and now it's gone his generation treated
emotions the way the mafia treated
people who turned
against them
they put that [ __ ] in the damn thing
bury him and don't even look for it
you're never gonna find him
don't you cry i'm gonna put a cement
block around your goddamn ankle okay
don't you [ __ ] cross me so he's you
know
he just was a very affable human being
and the alcoholism
although we were like well it's probably
too much it wasn't enough for us to be
like
let's have a conversation intervention
you can't do that with someone in their
70s
you have an intervention with someone in
their 70s it's not going to [ __ ] work
no
you all want to talk hang on let me get
a vodka
that's actually what it's all about
let me get tuned in
you saying we're going to be a while can
i get some chicken wings
i like them naked
he um so when we brought him to this
neurologist
she chopped up his vertigo
to drinking she said well you know you
do
it does look like you drink a little too
much and why don't we
why don't we cut that out and she's like
but it's very important that you
go slow cutting it out because your body
has become dependent upon it your brain
your chemistry is altered to be able to
facilitate the alcohol so you can
function on a daily basis so your entire
brain chemistry
evolves around the way you drink and how
you consume alcohol
and it's very very very important for
people who are alcoholics or
whatever type of addict you gotta go
slow when you come off of it you can't
go cold turkey
and especially this was something
another revelation and another
thing that we found out certain
cert certain brain diseases and like i
said before like neurodegenerative
things
can be exacerbated through the
immediate pulling away of
i see of a vice like drinking so can i
ask you this
maybe you know this one as well my same
friend of mine his mom who who lost his
sister
she's like a mom growing up to me still
but um
both of her parents um within a year of
each other both got it
her dad got it first um and then
they had to take away like one night he
just showed up in the garage with his
shotgun and there was
thank god but the doctor's like yup what
did the wife say
all the shotguns take every because he's
a hunter like put it all away
like and she's like i don't even think
of like he knows where that is i don't
cause she had to move in to take care of
him she's like i don't know where the
[ __ ] his guns are
um and then um his wife got it a year
later
like after his passing and one of the
things the doctor said
was to take away artificial sweeteners
and she said that she really noticed the
difference
in clarity in her parents when they
didn't have drinks that had artificial
sweeteners and i was just curious
because you said diet you brought up a
lot of these things do you know about
any of that sort of stuff
sugar's pure poison sugar right even
regular sugar too okay
it's pure poison it it's it
it affects so much you know it's it's
just honestly
what when i think back to you know the
development of the disease within my
father he had an enormous sweet tooth
he did yeah are you kidding me but all
that alcohol turns into sugar
it sure does end of the day it's and
that's what i'm saying like it's such a
like an amalgamation of so many things
it's your diet it's your lifestyle and a
big part of that is community and
you know being able to be social we're
social creatures
right and that's a huge when you think
about us just being in quarantine
i don't know about you but i came out of
quarantine not really being able to have
a conversation or speak in full
sentences because i was out of practice
because i just was hanging out with you
know toddlers and dogs
and when you know you meet people and
you have a mask on it's so when you
start to degenerate a little bit
just on the basis of being in quarantine
and not being in a community and talking
and imagine what what happens to
somebody who's already sort of
predispositioned to
develop a disease like alzheimer's or
something like parkinson's
so there's so many factors that if you
restrict them from your life
can sort of become the thing that
that makes it you more susceptible to
developing that
but um yeah she chopped it up to him
needing to stop drinking and and because
my father was the way he was
a little stubborn doesn't really listen
to the details doesn't follow orders
he stopped drinking abruptly and that
was in august
okay he stopped drinking abruptly in
august he didn't go slow
and by september whatever disease had
been like i said before
building through decades had just
bloomed
really within a month do you think him
going cold turkey like that helped
accelerate that
100 percent yes and and that's something
that it's only and
in the same breath the alcoholism sort
of subdued the symptoms
oh i see so it it becomes what's you
know it's just
dad versus something buzzed versus
something's wrong i see
okay all right cause he's always been a
little like he'd call me
and i actually have this plaque in my
house right now where he wrote me a note
and it says la um hey chris care
m nancy jess he used to call me and go
through the names of every woman he ever
met or knew
and then finally land on mine yeah but
what is it what is this bingo what is
happening
is that fish and pole cutlass supreme my
grandma's to do it i'm like
you just threw the dog in like nobody's
pepper you don't have any relative nate
pepper
okay that's the dog grandpa who's
cracker
who the hell is cracker
and so that sort of him
you know the disease had already sort of
manifest and show itself
by august because he was sort of having
this equilibrium issue
and then the abrupt you know
halt of drinking just it was a perfect
storm for the disease to be like hey it
was like beyonce getting rid of the two
others
yeah yeah there goes destiny
oh it's just beyonce now [ __ ] i am here
and i need diet coke on my rider and so
his
disease his disease had a time to shine
and you know my mom going
over in september was when we really
realized something was wrong because he
had sort of incubated himself he
um pulled away he withdrew from hanging
out at the bar
and ironically because he was at this
drinking hole all the time the change of
pace in syracuse
being there sort of gave him purpose
he had community he had friends he'd
play bar keno he hung out
they knew his drink um it was his
his space so there's so many things when
i look backwards i get so frustrated
because
in my mind i always think like what what
if he just kept drinking
what if he stayed the happy drunk he was
do you think he would be
here still i don't know and that's why
like when you ask those questions you
can't really
harp on them too long because the what
ifs and the hypotheticals drive you
crazy
but it's definitely something that i've
asked to myself into the universe
and maybe so you know but it just was
the perfect storm for him
to quit drinking and then that thing
that sort of gave him purpose
gave his disease a stage and then he
withdrew and so when he withdrew he
stayed at his apartment
he wasn't washing he wasn't quite
finding the bathroom the way he should
and by the time my mom went over on that
day with his trunk open and going
upstairs
it was a different person he had a beard
my father never [ __ ] had a beard are
you kidding me
an italian and upstate italian man
with a couple wives and a bunch of
daughters
and like 45 used cars
that man doesn't have a beard he dresses
knifes
nice and shaves every day and so
he just it was like
you know a surprise party it was a
really shitty surprise party that we had
where alzheimer's just showed up or
vascular dementia
here's the thing we talk about we we
always talk about how
we feel about this and our process of
what we went through and we went through
and
you know dying is a very lonely uh
thing you're you're going out on your
own we we lose this one person they lose
everybody your dad loses all the cars
and
all the all the daughters the golf clubs
the clubs the xy
all the vodka sodas all the soda all of
them
um so there's two things i want to talk
about and one
is his point of view first because
i've mentioned this show before but you
may have seen if you haven't you should
watch it
um but it's called you don't know jack
hbo did this documentary
about jack of orchian wow um and pacino
plays them
and they intercut it with real footage
of kavorkian and like the sort of this
documentary style yes i did see that i'm
gonna have to rewatch it
it was i remember it being fascinating
and i remember
the so what they did was they used
interviews of the real people he would
talk to
in within the documentary and um he
didn't charge
um he just asked you pay for his airline
ticket and he would come out
and he said you better be ready to go
like make your piece with each other
um and he would show you how it would go
he put a needle in you and
the body would sort of rise and it would
exhale and they're gone
they're gone peacefully not ugly there's
no vulgar shaking
and vomit and spit nothing it's peaceful
um but there was one point where this
was always stuck out to me this one lady
she said um
she stood in her backyard and for 30
minutes
she didn't know where she was and then
it clicked and she said to her husband
listen
if that happens again more than
twice a week call him and she said one
day she just was out there for hours
and then it hit and she's like all right
i'm i don't even
i don't even know my backyard anymore
like she had lost everything
but had a moment of clarity where she
was like i'm ready like let's do this
and
i just wonder like what you're if you
even know like what your dad
went through like did you have
conversations were you able to have
conversations like do you do you
understand what's happening you're
losing your mind like were you
was he that present or did it or this
alcohol thing happened so fast you
really didn't even get time
you know i wasn't expecting you to say
it went from a to z
within like a month it and we weren't
either i mean that's why
it was diagnosed as vascular dementia
usually that's brought on by a stroke so
they think maybe somewhere along the
line he had a stroke and we don't
know and that's another hard thing to
detect
um we were
there are those like moments of hope
like the lucidity
and so there were early on i remember us
having a conversation because we
we had to get home care because we
didn't we we didn't know
what it was right we didn't know what it
was for months
and that's why this disease is so
[ __ ] brutal because by the time
you have some sort of definitive
diagnosis
you're already 20 30 40 grand in the
hole with home care oh
yeah your stress every we were all
stretched so [ __ ] thin and mind you
i'm on the west coast i'm having i was
flying home
to syracuse all every month every time i
could
in between shows layovers whatever i
could do
um and my sister dealt with everything
and it just was such a
a scramble and
you know we're trying like the sort of
thing where you you know
try and do all these [ __ ] diets we
were doing the same thing for his mind
we're like well
we'll cut out this so i'll bring over
more blueberries like we didn't know
what the [ __ ] to do
we were just trying to like we were
literally plugging holes in a ship that
was already sunk
and that made it difficult you know
there's another there's a couple things
about this disease it's one of the most
expensive diseases to have
because of the home care inevitable home
care
inevitable memory care facility
the amount of money it takes to care for
somebody
on a 24-hour clock is exorbitant
and it's [ __ ] criminal personally and
i'm not saying people don't deserve
those those people who take care of home
health aides oh yeah they deserve
every damn dollar but the fact that
that's not something
that is readily available for people and
is something that's covered to me is
criminal
because this is a disease that society
our food and companies that are making
the food
is directly affecting they are a part of
the process
but that's another conversation um but
it is it was difficult for us you know
we had to have
a conversation with him where we had to
be like we have to
put you somewhere and like just we never
thought that would be the thing with him
you know we weren't we we we we weren't
we're close we we loved him like we
that wasn't something that we wanted to
do with either of our [ __ ] parents
and him being the stubborn italian
you know we went to start to go look at
places for him to go
and i got to tell you [ __ ]
walking into one of those places you're
like
i can't put him here
it just it it feels like it's like such
a um
helpless feeling it feels like you're
gripping
soap and it's wet and you just you keep
grip and it keeps slipping
and it gets smaller and smaller and
smaller like that's what what this
disease feels like
but we did you know there were moments
of some lucidity but those
they just they become shorter
less frequent but the the irony of that
and you know we can go into whatever you
want to talk about
is the scarcity made that made it more
special those
lucid moments not knowing when they were
going to come or what they were going to
be or how long they were going to last
made them the most
valuable thing in life at that time
but you know i remember going home early
on and
i had gotten a mattress sent to me from
this company
well i won't say because they haven't
treated us as nice as coors
of course pure
this mattress company had sent me a
mattress
and i had it sent to my dad's house
because i was like well since he's
soaked his entire mattress and his peed
in every corner maybe we can
put a little something nice in the place
just for now we were literally doing
anything we could to
we were doctoring up a crack [ __ ] you
did leave him there
he's still there we think
let's take a quick break and tell you
about our first sponsor upstart if you
have multiple credit cards you know that
tracking multiple balances due dates
website logins all that stuff can be
stressful
upstart makes things simple with one
monthly payment
in one place upstart is the fast and
easy way to get a personal loan to pay
off your debt all
online whether it's paying off credit
cards consolidating high interest debt
or funding personal expenses over half a
million people have used upstart
to get a simple fixed monthly payment
upstart finds smarter rates with trusted
partners because they assess more than
just your credit score with a
five-minute online rate check you can
get approved the same day and you can
receive your funds as fast as one
business day if debt is taking over your
life it's time to get a fresh start
with upstart listen i know you guys use
upstart you hit me up about it
you've gotten great rates you've gotten
uh consolidation one monthly payment i
wish i had something like upstart back
in the day
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com
honeydew that's upstart.com honeydew
don't forget to use my url to let them
know
i sent you loan amounts will be
determined based on your credit income
and certain other information provided
in your loan application
go to upstart.com honeydew our next
sponsor is raycon
whether it's for work or play a lot of
us are going to be on the move again
this summer
all right i'm going traveling i'm going
to baltimore
i plan on going visiting family i plan
on doing a lot of getting out there now
especially that i'm vaccinated all right
uh and i wear my raycons everywhere i
just was down in mexico took my raycons
i'm out by the pool with my raycons in
mexico
listen to what i want to listen to
they're fantastic
people keep asking me how do they stay
in they have adjustable earbuds
you put them right in i'm telling you
raycons are great i use them
my stepson took them won't even give
them back my other pair i had to get
another pair so whether you're
working out a pair of raycon wireless
earbuds in your ears can make all the
difference you get crisp
powerful beats at half the price of
other premium audio brands
raycons look great they feel even better
they come in a range of cool colors
and with customizable gel tips included
for a comfortable in-ear fit and they
have multiple sizes they will fit your
ears for sure
and raycons are built to go wherever you
go they have quick and seamless
bluetooth pairing
24-hour battery life and a compact
charging case
i'm telling you i take them everywhere
with me on walks
to traveling i give them to the kids in
the car
so listen up raycon's offering 15
off all their products for my listeners
and here's what you got to do to get it
go to buy ratecon.com
honeydew there you'll get 15 off your
entire raycon order
and it's such a good deal you want to
grab a pair and a spare that's 15
off at byraycon.com honeydew by raycon
dot com slash honeydew our next sponsor
is coors pure do you ever feel the
pressure to keep up a healthy life
like you try to get a workout daily you
eat healthy 100 of the time
you keep up with the wellness trends you
feel like you're trying so hard all the
time and sometimes
the simple act of using a standing desk
or getting a quick run in
is enough to celebrate well let me tell
you something
celebrate those everyday triumphs with
coors pure i celebrate i come in here i
sit down ash and i record
we do our ads we do our patreons we do
the episodes
i go outside i don't have a ticket i go
home i have a course pure it's a 70
ticket here in santa monica it's
expensive and they're cleaning these
streets
all the time doesn't look like it though
coors pure is all about promoting
balance and giving aggressive
affirmations to everyday heroes coors
pure is the perfect beer
to celebrate the winds of everyday life
so when you want to enjoy a beer without
the guilt
reach for coors pure it's organic but
chill about it go to coorspure.com
to see where you can find coors pure
celebrate responsibly coors brewing
company albany georgia look
you can find them everywhere they're
hard to find sometimes in the liquor
store because everybody's snatching them
up but i found them at target
go get your course pure at target now
let's get back to the duke
i really wanted to ask you because i
gotta feel like you feel like you're
abandoning your own dad you're leaving
him in this building and then
off you go it that's exactly what it
feels like
and we oh i'm just trying to put myself
in your dad's position
like watching you all leave like what he
was like there's no the first place we
went to
there just was no [ __ ] way and
it was all my sisters and my dad i i
just i felt his energy and my
out of all my sisters i was the closest
with my father him and i had a very very
very special bond and he loved all of us
equally me definitely more i definitely
was a favorite but
i even asked him when he was like on his
death but i'm like don't you [ __ ]
forget
don't you go haunting don't be telling
people you forgot you said that
you go haunt them write it down write it
down
we went we shopped around you know we
because it was such a
brutal decision and also
we didn't know what we were doing or
what we were up against still we just
knew he needed help we had no
definitive diagnosis for a month and a
half
maybe two months he had a home care
nurse who would come for a couple hours
and then she would say hey
this is not a four-hour job because it
would progress
so fast we literally got you know with
alzheimer's
you know there being um so many types of
dementia alzheimer's being the
the number one there is
just so many other variables that go
along with it you know in in
for on average people suffer with the
disease eight to ten years
from from wow i didn't realize it was
that long eight to ten years of them
being in the symptomatic
right era of alzheimer's dimensions
until the last year of that right well
you you you probably would know but
what i'm saying like i said before
decades of the disease
taking up residency in your body and
then manifesting itself it's such a slow
burn by the time the symptoms really
start to
get into the later stages because
there's a few stages of it
that's when it's snowballed yeah that's
when it starts to snowball but eight to
ten years
our dad had the silver lining the
highlight was that
we got a crash course it was a year
a year which is so unheard of when it
comes to this disease
i'm saying i didn't expect to hear you
say a year a year
we got 10 years of the illness in a year
it was it was the cliff notes of it and
you know most people would think oh man
that's not enough time to say goodbye or
to tie your loose ends i didn't have any
of those with him
we we sucked the life out of each other
not to say i wouldn't want him around
now but
there's no way i'd be sitting here with
you
looking as good as i do in these
quarantined titties and you look great
thank you
if my father was suffering for eight
years of this disease or still
if i'm three years in i would i would be
a [ __ ] mess
so that's like the silver lining of this
whole scenario
but you know
leaving him we we ended up on a assisted
living
which is so hopeful you're basically
like something's wrong
he can still handle himself by the time
you know we found this really cute place
where there's always like we try to sell
it to him like
hey it's like
[Laughter]
i can't wait to hear this sale it's like
hedonism
but with bibs and walkers
titties and all still there just covered
up by the bibs you heard of a moo moo
every everybody's already bending over
you know
because of osteoporosis
got free viagra at the commissary
there's no lap dances
just laps because everyone's sitting
down
every dance is a laugh
[Music]
it's it's so we were i say hopeful
because
you know this disease isn't it's not
neat it's not like you can go okay by
month two he's gonna be in stage two
and this is the stage and here's the
book for that
it's it's such that's why it's so
expensive and so emotionally
taxing because it goes like this
it's like you go back oh you get hopeful
and then you're three stages deep and
then you come back a little bit you're
like oh it's getting better and then he
doesn't know who the [ __ ] he is
did you ever have the conversation with
him that you're you're lead you're dying
you're going to die and did you get to
say a goodbye when he was coherent like
were you
where he actually knew what was
happening to him yeah i got to
do that um he was in
the hospital um nurse he was in a
nursing home
actually no he was in the hospital
because i think he had fallen
oh no he threw [ __ ] he threw [ __ ] actual
[ __ ]
yeah yeah he threw it was his [ __ ] he
threw it at his
roommate which he probably deserved if i
said something rude
no that's how monkeys used to solve
problems and now my dad does it he's an
[ __ ]
come on maybe he's just resourceful
maybe he's just a straightforward
italian he's like what'd you say to me
yeah i'll tell you what i'm gonna give
you a whole slice of this bullying ace
oh yeah
i got a calzone coming your way i want
my own room okay
so i appreciate to sacrifice you
yeah there's corn in it yeah they fed me
corn last night by the way
that's a surefire way to get your own
room bro
she's like dad through [ __ ] like he
threw a fit
she's like well yeah but it was a fit
filled with [ __ ] [ __ ]
i think that's where [ __ ] fit comes from
throwing a [ __ ] fit and i laughed and
i i'm such an [ __ ] like what did his
roommate do
what did harry do
harry didn't do anything my dad just
woke up and didn't know who harry was
and why was he in his room
and so like the rainbow trajectory of
his
assisted living facility placement was
we walked into
a you know nursing home we said [ __ ]
that we found an assisted living we
started to fill out the paperwork for
that
but by the time the paperwork was filled
out and he was accepted he had already
advanced too much for them to take him
because you have to be somewhat
independent to live in assisted living
we didn't know that
and then we had to find a memory care
facility um we found one in staircase
that did
you know great work and you know
that whole process was just
like you were talking about like leaving
him there i
i don't have any kids i don't know what
it's like to leave them to go to school
and like that it's not like that at all
because
you're literally walking away from them
as you knew them and every time you
leave them you're leaving a piece of
them when you come yeah they're
different you don't even know how
different neither do they
no so you know
that part was really hard and then so
you know he went to the memory care
facility and then
it just progressed so fast so by the
time he was in the the hospital we were
talking about
end of life and hospice and what the
next
with him with his nurses and doctors and
our family not in front of him not in
front of him no
they did a lot of that and i had a
problem with this curious
what i'm saying it's his life like i'm
over here i'm the one that you got to
come wipe my ass
and do all this [ __ ] like tell me what
the [ __ ] going on i had a problem with
people talking over my dad yeah like he
was around him like he's not even
there yeah i get that and you know he's
not processing he says
i don't give a [ __ ] how do you know
right how do you know he won't process
it
no you're not in his brain you don't
know what he's retaining
right and nobody knows anything about
this [ __ ] disease we can't get
a control over it so don't stand here
and tell me that i'm being sensitive for
asking you [ __ ] to take the
conversation
how sensitive we're being asked here
good shot
dad you still got that arm dad
he's like i get a vodka soda i'm like
get him a [ __ ] [ __ ] soda
okay but to your question yes yes
i was fortunate enough to
say the things that people so often
don't get the
luxury to say and it was only it was on
the heels of my brother-in-law who had
been through a lot of loss
my brother-in-law was just so such an
amazing human
he saw this coming a mile away even
though we had all the hope in the world
he he
had been around enough death and he sat
us down he goes
you need to have the conversation with
your dad because sometimes the soul
hangs on
and you need to let him know that it's
okay to go
and a lot of this disease and so much in
life is
is normalizing
and improving our relationship with loss
and letting go the more we can let go
the more space we have for love in our
own hearts and the more we're able to
move through life without regrets in in
holding grudges and so
my brother-in-law steve said that to me
and we were at the hospital having this
hospice conversation in one of the rooms
and all my sisters were there and i
realized that that's a very you know
it's
who knows what everyone's schedule is
gonna be and how we're gonna be able to
do this
and so we went in with him and
he's sitting down and we're just kind of
petting him because after having that
[ __ ] heavy ass conversation of
what to do with your dad as a body
right man that's a problem as a problem
as something to handle
as something this thing we got to take
care of yeah like what do we do with
this knife
i don't know because nothing
is not just trying to lighten it up
every so often
bear it with or we take them home in a
jar you guys got a special little box
with a nut cremation
is there a scrotal urn
there's a business idea there is a dick
and ball [ __ ]
i think i bought a dick and ball
[Laughter]
daddy
so off of just that heavy ass
conversation i was like i'm not gonna
have any other
i'm not gonna have any other confidence
or motivation or
ability to say this if i don't say it
now and so we're all just kind of
surrounding him and i said
we're okay and and he wasn't
communicative at this point
he wasn't able to carry on a
conversation um
the last thing he laughed at was a fart
card was it because it was his birthday
so this whole thing was so you know i
told you
outside i believe everything happens for
a reason there were so many dates
that things happened and that were
instrumental you know from the date of
him
my mom telling me something was wrong
with him to the date of us saying
like verbally letting him know he could
go um
it was on his birthday she was there
which is also her birthday it's her
birthday
so she she got him the card and we were
trying to talk with him but it just was
impossible and
it was one of those cards where you open
it up and it makes a fart noise and he
could not stop laughing it's great all
right he could not stop
laughing and and there's a video you
know i documented this whole thing
there's a video of us singing i think we
were singing sinatra
he was and that's the other thing about
this disease music is
so no pun intended instrumental
when my friend helping a sister was in a
coma not to compare it but just to be
out they said the same thing like
keep the brain active you have to keep
the brain active that's what they said
they played they told us to bring in
music and everything yeah
music's huge and i learned that music is
one of the only things especially when
you're playing it it activates
all chambers and parts of your brain
it's one of the only things that does
that
and that's why people who get dementia
alzheimer's body
any of these sort of you know things
under the dementia umbrella
they will the music that they
thrived in usually it's around between
16 and 20 years old that's like your era
of music
if you play that music they remember it
and it's it's like a phenomenon that
they're able to retain
you know certain things that's why they
remember things out of the blue and
they're able to sing these songs
even though they're losing all their
other faculties
and um so that day i remember him
laughing at that fart card and we were
singing sinatra and
that was the only communication we were
able to do song and farts
that's it that's what we're
i mean look you come in like that and
you go out like that
yes and he wouldn't respond to anything
we said you know do you know who this is
do you know who that is
and can i ask you a question when's the
first time
he forgot who you were i'll tell you
that right after i tell you this
that's a great question um he wouldn't
respond to any of our
you know he didn't there's no
conversation being had and
and so we didn't even know if he was
going to understand us telling him he
could let go
and so we're there with him and and i'm
just telling him
i love you you know my sister karen i
was like karen is good and she was
saying she's good and she's happy and i
told him i was happy
and and that i was loved and he is loved
and he is safe
and he [ __ ] started to cry
no he
you could visibly see him register
what we said and like
that's why people who are dealing with
this disease
they need to know they are still there
they can hear you they can feel you they
can smell
they can taste they can all their senses
are still there they're just being
hijacked
by a really cruel cruel [ __ ]
individual
and to not deviate from how you'd
normally
love them to think that they can't
understand what you're saying
and that that release
that that ability to release him
changed everything for me as a
as a human like to tell the the one man
who didn't try to [ __ ] me how much i
love him
he just was such an amazing dad
he was he wasn't the the
he didn't have all his [ __ ] together and
he
he was a [ __ ] up at times and sometimes
you know
he wasn't so great with money but he did
not
he was not cheap with his love and he
he always told us he loved us and man
that's well said
it it's just that is well said it's it's
it's
who he was to his core and to be able to
release him
from the shackles of that [ __ ]
disease because who knows
like that dr uh you were talking about
the soul being in the mind
who knows how much of people who are
going through these things like my
father and people who are sick and comas
who knows how much of them are hanging
on because they haven't thought they
could let go well i i'm sitting here
just blown away by that like yeah
like almost like god thank you thank you
the burden is off of me
right and think about a parent's love
think about you
wanting to protect your daughter and
fighting tooth
and nail to be there for her through the
[ __ ] end that doesn't go anywhere
no but to hear her let you know that
it's it's everything it's it's it's
it's you paying your love forward you
know if you love something enough you
have to let it go the most unselfish
thing you can do it's the most unselfish
thing you do
fight push harder you can do this no no
enough is enough it's okay to quit it's
okay to stop yeah
it's like that homie at love actually
was trying to [ __ ] his best friend's
wife
you got enough now he shows up at the
poster boards
[Laughter]
that was me um but to be able to do that
was like
it wasn't only important it was like it
was i felt honor in it
yeah i felt i
felt pure
it was like the it was like the
crossroads of pure love and pain
and it was the most probably one of the
most defining moments of my life where i
i wasn't and not that i won't always be
his daughter but i became
i became a woman in that moment
and you know you asked me about the
first time he forgot who i went
to that how soon after that did he pass
within a week
within a week i think so okay less less
than two weeks for sure because he moved
to another he moved to
i think like a nursing home after that
because he was in the hospital yeah he
moved to a nursing home and he was gone
rather soon um
the first time he forgot who i was
you know first let me say marijuana was
amazing through this whole process for
me
for him or you i got him some
for both of us uh it really helped me
connect with
my anxieties and release them through of
a veil of love and not fear you know
through an understanding that
things happen things fall as they may
and
i can either i have a choice to fight it
or to learn from it and and to allow it
to change me and to know that whatever
change i go through that's going to be
something i can use to service other
people
and and that's how i approached it just
for my own survival
not in any other you know conscious
effort other than
i will fall the [ __ ] apart if i don't
turn this into something
useful and so i smoked a lot of weed
and there was one day he called me it
was like six o'clock
on um it was like a weekday i was
walking around my neighborhood in marina
del rey california
i'd have to call him a lot you know this
is before he got into
the hospital and nursing home i had to
call him a lot because he [ __ ] forgot
and he called me once and he was
talking about relations between
everybody because i was mentioning
people and they start to forget the
the web of connections within a family
and who's who
and so i mentioned emily my sister and
my mom nancy
and he goes okay now emily all right um
now how is she related to you
and also she's my sister and
nancy now now how how do i know her i
was like well that's your ex-wife you've
slung the dick a couple times you've
been in and out
um and the other thing to note for
people dealing with this disease is that
it is their world as you know it
it's it would behoove you to go along on
whatever ride they're on
if they say waffles are floating in the
air [ __ ] take a bite
pour out some syrup okay if they say
that you know ronald reagan was in their
room earlier
ask him what he said to them the more
you try to fight the world that they
are living in the harder it's going to
be for you to exist in it
and so not very well said also yeah
it's it's just what the revelations and
epiphanies i had with dealing with him
you just go along with it and and it's
more important to
reminisce than to ask do you remember
questions are very hard for people with
dementia and any sort of disease
like that obviously their brain is
having a hard time making connections
so you kind of let let them drive the
ship and it's just an easy easier
smoother ride
so we were going through this
conversation and
he's like okay now nancy as i got that
that was your
ex-wife she's she's still in your life
she loves you and he went
and i'm i'm high as [ __ ] i am like
two blunts deep and it's you know 5 p.m
and i'm just going through
living this brutal existence
and he goes okay now who are you
and i just i should have saw it coming
kind of like a [ __ ] who walks alone in
a parking lot at night
don't victim shame
don't victim shame you're getting
cancelled
don't you victim shame women who walk
alone in the parking garages at night
please just watch the first episode
you'll understand why i have the rape
card
in my back pocket
[Laughter]
you should have saw the rapist coming
you know i should have i didn't i guess
because i just was in the moment
and that's one of the most important
beautiful things you can be in life but
also in dealing with somebody who's
going through this sort of disease being
in the moment is survival and i was so
in the moment
he took me off guard he said well who
are you
and i just took a hit of my joint i was
just like
that's a good [ __ ] question
i'd even i'd even consider he forgot me
i just thought he was getting
existential
and i was like i don't i'm everybody i'm
you
you're me who's anybody
you know i i truthfully
i didn't equate it to him for getting me
i equated it to me and this is gonna
sound
real real woo-woo i equated it to me
needing to forget who i was
because i was no longer her because this
whole experience
changed me to my core and it was just an
opportunity to get to know who this new
person was within this life of losing
the most important person
i've ever known and i just said
you know what i'm your favorite daughter
and what do you say and you owe me five
hundred dollars a
thousand dollars he just is like oh
oh okay i'm sorry i
that was nice he said i'm sorry yeah you
know
because there's so much shame and
dignity lost through this disease
like we talked before people talking
over them because they just can't
they're they're crazy and and and them
losing control of their bodily functions
and
and them losing relationships and it's
all loss
and you have to grieve the person while
they're alive
that's the hardest [ __ ] you're not
only
plugging holes in a ship that's already
sunk
you are having to say goodbye to a
person you love every single day you're
losing them every day
you're having to learn how to grieve
well
you know i look at my sister emily who
just
i was so amazed by her strength she's
got
kids and a husband and is has her own
life and she
was the [ __ ] point guard for it all
and my mom in tandem with my mom my
other sisters helped
but emily really grabbed the reins
and handled all the medical stuff took
care of the
home care aide just [ __ ]
bucked the [ __ ] up and was able to
get through it and help my dad maintain
some dignity in the process
so that we weren't just taking whatever
we got we were challenging the system a
little bit so that we could get the best
we could for him
you know and do you remember if he
is this is something i want to know
about people i know they forget
things where they are you know do they
forget who
they are yeah do they is there a point
where your dad
literally just is like doesn't remember
anything
yeah they become they become very
vegetative
they do and it's there the moments of
lucidity
oh god it's just like i feel like
lucidity is kind of like that girl
trying to get in on a double dutch
just trying to find the opportune moment
just to get in and play for a minute and
then she's gone that's what those
moments are like
you know they pop in and you're just
like and you
[ __ ] grab onto it as a loved one and
you
are like ugh and then it's it's gone
you know and those moments became few
and far in between but like i said they
were the most
magical moments because i knew that
about them i took him
one of the times i came home i took him
to a restaurant
and this is when he was in the memory
care facility this is three stops before
his last stop
and as far as the facilities he was in
and you know you talk about him losing
himself
that for me was the hardest part because
i'm like losing my guy and his
personality and all of that
changing so much i brought him out to
lunch and we walk in he's got his walker
and he's slow
he's taking everything in like it's new
they become very childlike
and everything's kind of new and he just
looks a little out of sorts and
taking it all in and then we get up to
the hostess sand
and the hostess is pretty he's like oh
and he kind of like perks up a little
i'm like okay we still got it and then
we walk and we sit down
and the waitress comes over and she's a
knockout you know she's like older woman
but just gorgeous
and she goes so would you you guys know
what you're going to have
and my dad goes i'll have you if it's on
the menu
he's like i've swung this thick
successfully a few times
okay and she just looked at me i'm like
that's my
dad yes he will have you
i don't care if it's on the menu or not
[ __ ] you are being had
it it's that's great you know those
those things happen they give you so
much hope if you're somebody who
doesn't you know at that point we had
already sort of deduced what was going
on because he was in a memory care
facility at that point
but leading up to that those moments can
be really tricky
they're you know it's like a fix and you
you're like oh
he's gonna be good and i was an eternal
optimist through
him the entire time i just
tried to find the silver linings that's
how i've survived my entire life
it's probably the reason why i haven't
become some crack [ __ ]
because i i'm just eternally optimistic
there's a lot of positive [ __ ] crack
horses believe me i thought about it
during quarantine i'm like
there's another positive crackers out
there they're not all you know
pessimistic
i can wear an outfit no one will judge
me they'll be like oh you're a cracker
fish nets make sense yeah rich ones at
that
um he uh
yeah it just you know towards the end
like him showing his personality became
just fewer and fewer times and and
those are the moments that i just
you just sort of sit and you're quiet
and that's that's my other word of
advice is just to
be as quiet as you can communicate with
them but let them
really drive the ship i remember one
time i picked him up
and this is one of the only times where
i was so irate
him and i were in the car and we were
singing sinatra it was just like a
like half a mile drive from his memory
care facility
in syracuse to the restaurant and we
were singing sinatra at the top of our
lungs i think it was my way
no you make me feel so young singing it
and he knew the words
and then we pull up we're meeting my
sister and my brother-in-law
we pull up and we're sitting there and i
go to get out of the car and he goes
man i miss you and i
i was like what he was like i i have
missed you so much
i just i want you to know
i love you so much and i don't know
what's happening
but i just i miss you and we were having
this moment
and just as he was about to say
something else my brother-in-law came up
and like knocked on the window and
that moment was just shook out of
the car and i had to sit in the car for
a minute i had to like really like
getting emotional they got him out and
his
walker was in the back and i had a sort
of like all right
steve didn't know what was going on this
is all
new to all of us and you had somewhat of
a moment
you can't you can't try and grab on to
what
could have been but those
those things happen so infrequently that
they become
so profound in their scarcity they
become
it's i've been thinking about that the
whole time about how
you know we take a lot of things for
granted in life but just a conversation
with someone i'm
i you know then you're begging to hear
anything they have to say
begging from especially a moment of
clarity you know
time yeah time at the end
is what most people want more of nothing
else
no not a better car or a better [ __ ]
couch
no not even food time time
and that's what changed for me was how
who and where i spent my time with
because every moment with him hit me
so [ __ ] hard that it like
knocked it knocked my
it knocked me senseless it changed me it
changed
how i stepped out into the world and how
i presented myself and how
i lived in a moment and
you know after um after he passed away
i've spent every holiday with my
families we're very
with my family we're very close i'm a
huge homebody i love being
home with my family when i was living in
new york i was home every weekend
so holidays are very important to me and
after my father died everything changed
because
he wasn't going to be there and so i
decided to go do a uso tour
and be away from my family and sort of
recalibrate and get used to that new
normal
and when i was over there i was reading
something
and i forget who said it maybe somebody
can send me a dm or i can look up
afterwards but the saying is you never
know the value of a moment until it
becomes a memory
and that encapsulated everything for me
during that process of losing my dad
from him being
you know trying to call somebody on his
remote to
him finally passing and
sharing is so important talking about it
is so important
you know sharing our experiences and
everything is the most
i think that's service you know you
doing this podcast is
huge service because it opens people up
to their trauma and let them know that
that they're not alone and
and i learned that in a really beautiful
way you know by sharing everything on
instagram
john hefron he reached out him and i
never met
physically but i of course know who he
is as a comedian yeah
and he saw all the stuff i was sharing
and he went through a similar scenario i
believe with his mother
i apologize if that's the wrong parent
but both mine are dead so
um which is going to be installment
installment three we'll get to nancy no
pants nance um
that's what my fans call called my mom
no pants dance that's a whole story
we'll
we'll save it for you um
that john sent me a message and he said
you know i'm going through something
similar i went through something similar
and i just want to let you know
that hearing i've learned is one of the
final
senses to go so people can still hear
even though they
appear vegetative maybe in a coma
maybe they're not responsive that the
the belief
and what people have said is that
hearing is the last to go
and you know up into that point i had
written on my mirror
call your dad as a reminder to me
because i was so scared to do it
i'm sorry
literally making me cry over here
this is what i get for screaming it's
just the latex
[Laughter]
oh these are hybrid tears of joy and
pain here
those are the two those are all the
tears
because i was so scared i was so scared
of what he wasn't going to say or what
he wasn't going to remember or what he
what what wasn't going to be i just was
so fearful that i wrote it as a reminder
on my mirror to just do it every day
and this was during a time when my dad
after i had sort of had the conversation
of him being able to
you know letting him go i had flown back
to la because i still was hopeful that
he was going to pull through
that's how delusional i was during this
um
and i was very scared to call
during that time because he couldn't
talk and i thought what's the point and
then i was like
what's the point oh could someone hold
it for you yeah
yeah get that garth brooks heads up that
[ __ ]
chris gaines easy rider on your mouth
where's my hearties headset goddamn
my daughter's calling one of them i
think i can take a two-piece is that you
chris where's my vodka soda
um you know he told me that and
it just it struck a chord with me and
i had a show that night
and i still hadn't called my dad it had
been a couple days and i thought about
what john had said
and so you know earlier that day i had
had an
extreme panic attack for some reason i
just felt like this visceral anxiety i
called my sister i said you gotta get to
dad
and she's like it's fine it's okay i'm
like no you need to get to him you have
to go
and be with him i just had this like
tangible visceral anxiety that came out
of nowhere i had a complete panic attack
in the grocery store i thought the world
was ending i thought i was dying
and i told my sister she needed to get
with my dad and
i went home sort of calmed down read
john's message again
and just kind of thought about it and i
was like i'm too i was too scared
and then i went and did my show and i'd
come come home late you know i was like
midnight or something
and like waited another about an hour or
so and i just
i it's like a new relationship like i
just want to talk to him you know i just
wanted to like talk to him and
and so around two i finally got the
balls to call
his his his nursing home
and i called and this woman
karen answered and i said is my dad
still with us
and she said yeah and i said well this
is jesse
his daughter his favorite one can you
can you just tell him i called him that
i love him and i'm thinking about him
and she said i'll go right in right
after hang up with you and i'll go tell
him
and she did that i fell asleep and my
sister called me 20 minutes later
he had passed away right after she said
that to him
and and i say that because
jon hafron gave me such a gift
and i say that because by sharing what
your trauma is you give other people
gifts that they didn't even realize they
had yeah
i didn't even realize that i had that
had it not been for john heffron saying
hey he can still hear you know even
though i told him he could go
he probably still was hanging on in
fighting and fighting and fighting and
we have to show up for the people we
love in in the hour of their need and
release them as much as possible and
i wasn't able to be there for
either of my parents passing away
which is so hard but
if your love is you don't need a
physical presence
because love permeates that's right this
stuff
love permeates stuff it's not
it's not in things it's in people and so
as long as
i felt that i felt peace and being able
to say goodbye
through somebody else you know through
the voice of another woman but he knew
it was me
that's right and i have no
rock unturned none most people don't
have that
luxury i mean you you're you're
fortunate with it it was so
fortunate because i'd be such a filthy
[ __ ] if it weren't
the other way yeah you would you'd be so
you'd be used to be out there past [ __ ]
that latex in your puzzle you'd be
i tell people all the time talk about
their therapist and lithium i'm like
love
not lithium oh my god you just need love
you just need to be loved
you don't need lithium no you don't need
all these things you just need some
[ __ ] love
you need love and you need to release oh
god
well listen i uh you got me over here a
mess
i'm over there like my dad's dead you're
like call your dad
first thing i'm thinking is stella
writing that and then i'm thinking about
mom i'm like oh
you got me girl you got me this was
fantastic thank you
help so much of people i hope so and it
will if anybody needs information
especially if you're in a place where
it's getting expensive or you think you
might be embarking on a home care
check out we are hilarity for charity
that's seth rogen and laura rogan's
foundation we are hfc they do amazing
work they give grants for family to help
them support the
cost and carry the cost of taking care
of your loved ones
alzheimer's association has a lot of
resources there's a lot of independent
chapters in each of your
cities um you know there's
there's a lot of books and things out
there
but experience is probably the greatest
teacher when it comes to this sort of
disease because it's not a textbook
scenario and you know if anybody wants
to dm me
i would be happy to help you if i have
time to just let you know share with you
what's worked for me but like i said
let it be their life let it be their
existence as they know
it music is your best friend marijuana's
great
um patience and and forgiving yourself
and make sure that you don't you know
tr you try to
realize that what's going on isn't them
don't take it personally it's
the disease they might get irate and say
things and try and hit on you
or right you know my my dad hit on my
sister and i was like what the [ __ ]
he never lost it the whole way i'm the
hot one
that's how you knew he was a woman my
dad's sick
we gotta shut it down he just tried to
hit on karen
and i'm not i have a have you seen these
quarantities
i'm gonna push up ron rouge
stick him in the [ __ ] the cheapest
home you got
tip them out of that wheelchair god damn
it um
please again plug everything you'd like
um
sharp tongue podcast check it out weeds
day almost every wednesday we get a
little stoned and we raise awareness and
and charity for alzheimer's
also my youtube page check out mud water
the code is jessie mae mud first a
discount on your
on your mud and have faith and lead with
an open heart
i love you i love you too this was
awesome it really was please come back
and let's have another sesh i feel like
i owe you 350
for this hour you're good girl you're
good just have another coors pure with
me
organic but chill about it uh ryan
sickler on
all social media ryan sickler.com thank
you all so much
uh we'll talk to you all next week
[Music]
you